senator how frustrated what frustrated
were you today
uh very number one he's a fine man
but he's making stuff up about the pull
factors here's what i was trying to tell
him
if you talk to the border patrol agents
in charge of trying to police our border
they're under siege they're american
patriots right after the election they
told the byte administration if you
eliminate the remaining mexico policy
and go back to catch and release when it
comes to asylum claims will be overrun
if you start allowing unaccompanied
minors the ability to stay in the
country not send them where they came
from
there'll be more of them and everything
that they said has come true
and here's what secretary of agriculture
either he doesn't understand
it well number one i said when's the
last time you talked to the border
patrol he said 10 years ago
so he's telling me about the border i've
been there more times than i can count
i've been working on illegal immigration
to try to fix it for 15 years so you
have a cabinet secretary
telling me stuff about pull factors and
he hadn't talked to the border patrol in
10 years
so i'm tired of this crap so what's
happened here brian
is that the biden administration was put
on notice right after the election
that if you change trump policies if you
stop building the wall
you go back to catch and release allow
people to come in and make an asylum
claim
release them into the interior of the
united states will be overwhelmed and
overrun
and they were right and nobody in the
body administration
is adjusting they're denying the truth
secretary vilsack
has an important objective he wants more
workers for
farms fine and guess what that's fine
there's a thing called work visas
there's things that could be negotiated
you know what campaign negotiated
188 000 illegals last month a 21-year
high
you know what also can't be negotiated
logic because joe biden knows better in
2006 he voted to build the wall
you know what jay johnson did in 2008
when he worked for president obama he
tried to secure the border
this is the first administration that's
ignoring a ongoing catastrophe
well when i asked him you're dead right
and president trump's statement
i hope you look at it and can talk about
it tonight is dead on
if you don't believe that giving legal
status to people who've been here
illegally for years
without first securing the border will
entice more people to come
you're crazy we've always done border
security first i've been involved in
every immigration reform proposal
in the last 15 years the democratic
party agreed with me and other
republicans to spend 40 billion dollars
to secure the border in 2013.
now i can't then i can't get them to
admit that the pull factors they created
are causing the flow of illegal
immigration there's nothing changed in
the triangle countries
they're no worse they're no better
what's changed as we changed our
policies
absolutely so there's a big thing here
and it all is wrapped in infrastructure
you guys are going to decide whether
you're going to move forward on
infrastructure the bipartisan bill
as early as monday today they wanted you
to have a vote the problem was
there was nothing to vote on you hadn't
written anything down yet so they have
it monday
but what they're going to do is take the
million people who have come over the
last six months
and try to wrap it into the 3.5 trillion
and say it's called immigration
infrastructure
if a palm parliamentarian won't stop it
that could actually
work for them well here's what you need
to understand
they're willing to do that they're
willing to take mail-in voting and put
it in the reconciliation package
to have their dream of melon voting as a
national standard which will be terrible
for for elections and terrible for
conservatism but the idea of giving
amnesty in an infrastructure package
would lead to a run on the border like
you've never seen
it will double or triple the not the
number of people trying to get into the
country
the day you legalize one person brian
without first securing your border
it spreads throughout the world and they
will come by the millions not by the
hundreds of thousands
and if you don't believe me ask the
border security people who are in charge
i challenge dick durbin today to have a
hearing on the status of the border
bring the professionals before the
congress and let's ask them
what has happened in the last six months
and if we provided legal status what
would happen
uh in the next six months they won't let
me ask those questions because they
don't want to hear the answers they
can't secure the border or they choose
not to real quick talking about
president trump
he says you guys are being played by
going for the bipartisan infrastructure
deal knowing everything you negotiated
out
is going to be jammed down your throat
weeks later are you being played
no i don't think so he had a trillion
and a half dollar infrastructure package
this is a tree and it's roads bridges
and ports
count me in for a facelift for america
when it comes to roads bridges and ports
count me out for three and a half
trillion dollar tax and spend a liberal
wishlist i
wish list i know the difference i think
it'd be good for the country to do
something together on roads and bridges
i think this idea of a three and a half
to five trillion dollar infrastructure
package grow the government
wrapped around with amnesty as a
disaster for our nation it will lead to
rampant inflation
and an invasion of illegal immigrants an
invasion of illegal immigrants
but you're almost helpless to stop it
exit question how many republicans would
vote for this
if it's the framework is written up the
way you think it is and you talked about
how many will vote for it if there's a
vote next week
uh probably about half i think half the
republican party understands we need to
do something on infrastructure paid for
not one republican will vote for the
three and a half trillion dollar
infrastructure package with amnesty and
melon ballots not one of us susan
collins not one because it would be a
disaster for the country
the people in charge of your government
right now are crazy
yeah and they're your colleagues thanks
and they know better
senator lindsey graham thanks so much